do you think
charm and Charisma selling yourself
today
is important for the scientists to be
able to win it or do you think
America is going to be okay to say no we
just want a guy that's going to get the
job done we don't care if a guy wants to
go out there and Shake Hands best Dev no
do any of that stuff do you think that's
necessary or no Americans are visual
Americans want folks to show whether
they like uh look go back in the the the
televised debate between Nixon and
Kennedy uh if you listen to it don't
look at it he listened to it it was it
was Nixon but the fact that Nixon looked
like he had five o'clock Shadows you
know Kennedy look young and in fact you
know Abraham Lincoln Abraham Lincoln
probably couldn't make it today and even
back then uh they said Abe you gotta
kind of like grow a beard because your
face it looks too Squad and everything
all his pictures he had the high collar
to to reduce the length of his neck I
mean America's visual go back to 2012 in
the election between Mitt Romney and uh
and Barack Obama the exit polls everyone
said who would have been better to
handle the comment Mitt Romney but who
did you like Barack Obama so there is an
aspect of it and what I what I tell
people all the candidates to say Hey you
know I'd like to get your endorsement
can you tell me what image and message
those are the two aspects of a person
running for office or campaign whatever
image and message the other side always
wins on image
because their message sucks
but people are so focused on their image
I mean Barack Obama I mean you looked at
him on television and you're just like
wow but it's the same thing you see
every single Sunday in the black church
you know the very charismatic pastor and
everything like that but if you just
read a speech of Barack Obama you would
say what in this what is he talking
about it's the same thing with with with
with Biden in a way so his image was
horrible so they put him in the basement
and nobody talked about anything what
did they do they attacked the image of
Donald Trump so yes you've got to go and
and look at the the charismatic aspect
of leadership but I wrote this down
because I knew you're going to come to
that leadership is about what the Army
taught me five C's
the first C is courage
people want to see a courageous person
they want to see a courageous leader the
second C is competence
because as you know no one follows a
dummy into a firefight so they want to
know they have a competent leader the
next C is commitment a commitment to a
core set of principles and values I mean
you can say what you want about Ronald
Reagan but you know he was committed to
America he was committed to the
Constitution he was committed to our
fundamental principles and values then
you got to be convicted that's the
fourth C because even when the winds
blow the polls say this whatever you got
to stay true north leaders stay true
north they committed to something and
they're convicted to and then the last
thing is character doing what is right
when no one's watching that's what I
taught soldiers that's what I taught my
daughter's five C's courage competence
commitment conviction and character
and when you understand that and you you
realize okay the two-faced image and
message and you bring all that together
you're powerful you're you're going to
win 49 out of 50. so what are you saying
about DeSantis to me has all five of
those I think he's got courage I think
he's got competence I think he's got
commitment I think he's he is conviction
he's got conviction I think he's a man
of character I think he's got those
things but this is a difference I want
to show you this this is Dr Albert
mehrabian's uh uh uh uh uh
738-55 Rule and I don't know if it's his
or somebody else's but I've seen this
and I've read this in books you've seen
it as well seven percent is a spoken
word today elements of communication 38
is voice and tone 55 is body language
does this favor DeSantis this is one and
you're gonna identify with this
remember when you first reported into a
unit yes I remember when officers
reported into me clearly knock on the
door they come in you're sizing them up
they're not saying anything you're
looking at their uniform you're looking
at their boots especially looking at
their haircut the comportment and
everything and then when they stand
before you they open up their mouth
either confirms or denies that 55 so
what are you saying what I'm saying is
that you've got to have that visual
appearance first and foremost well he
has the appearance and and I think that
everything falls from that it's just the
same as if I came in here and you know
I'm Lieutenant Carl retired Alan
Westwood I'm sitting over here with a
beard I'm 200 pounds overweight you're
gonna say what kind of curl was that guy
you know so you you have to present that
r that atmosphere I mean again Ronald
Reagan you know his body language his
his his physical presence he was an
actor he knew how to sell it comes back
what I say image and message and you've
got to win the image battle really
before you get to the message battle
which is what you say so so I'm again I
want to go back to it does he have the
complete package to win on the big stage
with the camera on him 24 7 having to
show some charm some Charisma some
vulnerability likability instead of just
what he does yes I I absolutely believe
he does and what's even better you know
what his greatest asset is
results his wife
who was in the media and so she will
make sure he knows how to do you know
bring that all together
that that's his wife you're saying yeah
that's that's as great and some people
said it wasn't a good look the way he
did media and I look I'll go to him but
I know I I saw him but he's got to learn
that I mean is that enough to learn in a
year he ain't got that much time because
before he announces it you know there's
a difference between going against the
Chris
there's I think the last time he had a
real battle was Gillum more than it was
Chris right so you know does you
remember when uh uh Rick Perry came out
I remember I was going to be the
president he's going to be president the
three three agencies oops oh man this
guy's done and he was on fire going to
California if you're sick and tired of
Regulation come to Texas we'll know how
to take care of him like I'm going to
Texas I want to met with him we're at a
Texas Rangers gonna discuss freaking
amazing the charm the Charisma this guy
could be a president one day boom
doesn't happen because of that so
there's a difference between big stage
and well I agree you know so this is the
part where there are a lot of people
that want this guy to do it there are a
lot of people that want this kid to pull
it off there's a lot that wandy but in
business and in leadership there's a
difference between wanting a guy because
you'll like him so much and it actually
happened and it ends up being another
guy that maybe you don't like that much
sometimes it's confusing
well yes but I will tell tell you that
if you make a mistake but people feel it
was an honest mistake and you own it the
American people are forgiving uh but if
you make a mistake and you're arrogant
about it uh they're not going to be so
forgiving and that's that's part of this
I don't think people are looking for
that perfect person uh I don't think
that that perfect candidate is what I'm
saying though because I think because I
because I actually think if if we are
looking for more the perfect person he
is more perfect then Trump is perfect
Trump has a hundred times more
imperfections than this guy's does we
can name different girls and we can go
through the imperfection list right so a
lot of people could say Trump is more
imperfect and he's perfect the other way
around so but to me I'm not coming from
policy I'm not coming from there's a
whole different criticism to say this
guy's more The Establishment than Trump
is and while we're going through a
season like this where you're talking
about China Iran Russia Saudi Juan you
know Ukraine Russia when you know what's
going on there Afghanistan stand you
know Taliban everybody's attacking us
internally the swamp dude you this there
needs to be somebody that's gone through
God knows how many different ways of
negotiation and the streets of New York
real estate some people are saying if
you are saying Alan the problem in the
world is so bad you need a scary type of
guy where they fear well the other side
is going to say holy this is not
the one guy I want to face off I would
much rather take a guy that knows how to
follow the guidelines to move up in his
career than another guy that's broken
the rules every once in a while where he
may be willing to go places that others
are not willing to go this guy doesn't
seem like he's here and what you just
did you you made the argument for a
George Patton George Patton had all kind
of flaws Eisenhower I mean he drove
patent drove Eisenhower crazy
but Patton understood one thing George
Patton won
and he knew that he needed him uh maybe
sometimes he had to put him in time out
like what you saw after the little
soldier slapping incident but he knew he
had to bring him off Sidelines and get
him back into the fight so you've read
the book Lincoln on leadership by Donald
D Phillips I think it's Donald Phillips
and he chapter 11 where he says search
until you find your Grant
and he has this guy named McClellan you
know yeah absolutely phenomenal right
but he was the trainer yeah he was a
thinker but he was a trainer he wasn't a
doer he wasn't a field General and then
he gets this guy never reports anything
back never tells him what's going on he
can't find where Grant is he's talking
about grants drinking he's doing this
he's doing that but at the end of the
day he wins he freaking wins becomes one
of the worst Presidents we've had he was
not necessarily the best president
interim president but he was a great
exchange leg for you know Lincoln hey
you do your part you win the war you
make make us look good you be the
president it kind of worked out for him
but to me I'm wondering if we have a
situation here like that I may be wrong
uh at the end of the day anything is
better than what we have today correct
anything is better than what we have
today
um you know Bill Maher the other day
called Trump he says I think Trump is
the greatest politician of all time he
says and I don't even think he knows
that he's a greatest politician of all
time I don't even think he knows that he
knows what he's doing but he's the
greatest politician of all time he said
this on the show last week said there is
gamesmanship here Alan this is a dark
world so for me if you're gonna call a
guy to be your captain you have to make
sure that Captain uh knows the dirty
side when I ran a small office
and I was an agent selling Insurance
nobody cared about me
Patrick's a nice guy
then when I ran a top office Insurance
in San Fernando Valley
people outside of San Fernando Valley
love me but people in San Fernando
Valley didn't like me so if I wanted
them all and I saw a competitor you
mother because I'm a direct competitor
but in San Fernando Valley we all went
to the same church we all went to the
same gyms the same LA Fitness the same
this the same that
so then all of a sudden I'm competing in
the state
then it's regional then it's National
the moment we became National and then
we started writing two three thousand
policies a month
then I all of a sudden realize
sting is real yeah a lot of these guys
were all sympathetic in understanding
why you're so great and now it's like
they're calling other insurance
companies for me to lose my contract got
it so this is the game I gotta go
read a bunch of war books yeah I got to
go read a bunch of 33 Strategies who are
the war power books then I understood
the game so the next level he's gonna go
into is gonna be a thousand times darker
than what it was on covet and if the
American people are going to say he's
the guy great I think he is a man of
character I think he is fully a man who
loves America I think he is a tough guy
but uh it'll be interesting how the
American American voter whether they
pick him and by the way it's still too
early to tell anyways everybody right
now is saying oh it's done Trump's going
to win the whole thing he's going to be
the president I don't think it's going
to be that way
because I think there's more dark
strategies that they have up their
sleeves that we don't know about but
that is the concern of a lot of people
when I talk to them so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]